Washington Post reporter Jason rezaian
had been living in Tehran for five years
when the Iranian government arrested him
back in 2014 his detention prompted a
544 day effort to free the Iranian
American which was tracked by CBS News
and other news organizations The
Washington Post says one of its
reporters working in Iran is apparently
being detained for nine months jason has
been imprisoned in Tehran for nothing
more than writing about the hopes and
the fears of the Iranian people Iran
hasn't produced any evidence against
Jason rezaian and many people both here
and in the u.s. think that he's simply a
pawn of hardliners who want to derail
the nuclear talks and destroy any chance
of better relations with America he's
very tired
he's very isolated these things keep on
coming up there's all these milestones
whether it's the UN General Assembly or
the nuclear deal all these things come
in he gets his hopes up that something's
going to happen and then nothing
happened a year and a half after he was
first locked up Jason rezaian was
finally reunited with his wife mother
and brother my Iranian interrogators
told me that the Washington Post did not
exist but no one knew of my plight and
the United States government would not
lift a finger for my release today I'm
here in this room with the very people
who helped prove the Iranians wrong in
so many ways rezaian rezaian writes
about his experience in his new memoir
it's called simply prisoner
we welcome you Jason rezaian to the
table thanks so much for having me can I
just say about your book it's riveting
because you really do take us behind the
scenes and I want people to really get a
sense of what you went through you and
your your wife yogi who's here in the
green room you're going down the
elevator the door is open there's a guy
standing there with a gun and before you
know it you're accused of having an
affair with the Polish ambassador's wife
that your marriage is a CIA plot and
that the whole thing's and that you're
doing something with avocados you just
blew me away cuz I never think about
avocados and nefarious in the same
sentence you shouldn't go jail you know
I think that amazing story thank you it
was a rapid-fire success
of every sort of accusation that you can
imagine and none of them held any water
and that's that's really the talk about
how the lunacy of the avocado story
because that's what kicked it all off
for you so I started a Kickstarter
project on the crowdfunding site several
years previously to our arrest and and
literally in my first interrogation I'm
being I'm blindfolded there are many
many people in the room and this voice
keeps telling me
we know that the avocado is a front for
some other kind of project we just don't
know what it is tell us what it is and
I'm you know at that point I'm a few
minutes into this ordeal I'm still
laughing thinking to myself it can't be
about this why do you believe that you
were arrested in jailed and held for so
many days in solitary confinement it
took me some time to really understand
this but I think I had a lot more to do
with the fact that I was an American
working for an American news
organization during a time of very
sensitive negotiations between Iran and
world powers there were forces inside
the Iranian regime that didn't want to
see those negotiations come to a
conclusion and so they were doing
everything they could to to throw rocks
at it that was one of those those
victims right were you concerned about
your safety though going in I mean we
should know you are an expert your
father's from Iran your mother American
you speak the language you are the
bureau chief there where you concern of
this scenario taking place look over the
years I've been working in Iran with
full permission
you know Iran's a sort of country where
you can't go and report from if you
don't have state permission I've been
working there for five years literally
the day that we were arrested July 22nd
2014 my wife and I she's also a
journalist had our accreditation
extended for another year on top of what
we had so you know I at various points
in those five years that I worked there
yes I was concerned about things that
were going on in the streets and around
us but I had gotten to that point where
I'd been living in this society for so
long knew the rules played by the rules
and this still happened it's amazing to
have you here and watch you talking so
that's just a blessing but
Viktor Frankl the famous writer about
the concentration camp said he who has a
why to live can bear almost any how yeah
so what was the why for you well first
and foremost you know being reunited
with my wife you know we had the good
fortune of her being in Iran as well and
after several months and and the raising
of awareness around my case I was given
the opportunity to see her from time to
time and she was you know real fuel of
that hope you know and she was the one
that was telling me hey you're never
gonna plead guilty you didn't do
anything wrong we're gonna get out of
this and you know we I think we
supported each other through a really
tough process and and knowing that that
the rest of the world was was really
behind us helped him thank goodness for
your brother thank your brother and your
mom he was really the true champion you
had many true champions but he kept your
name out there and I think people here
well you know you weren't physically
tortured so how bad could it have been I
really want people to understand exactly
how bad it was and what you went through
well literally from the first night Gale
they were telling me we're gonna cut
your head off I'm gonna behead you yeah
yeah and over over the the ensuing days
and you know when you're in solitary
confinement you're you blocked off from
from all reality they were telling me
that that had been already reported that
we died in a car accident that nobody
cares that the story has already blown
over there there is no story
it wasn't until many weeks later that I
realized well actually there are people
doing a great deal to to raise the
awareness around our plight and also
probably behind the scenes a lot going
on as well I couldn't know what those
things were but when it was over Jason
you hugged your interrogator I was
surprised at that look maintaining your
humanity Gail is is the most important
thing you can do and if you let go of
that what else do you have what is your
message to the families of the at least
six Americans who are either missing or
still detained in Iran right now well
you know my message to them is that my
great hope is that they'll be reunited
with their loved ones Iran has a very
long history of doing this to two
foreign nationals it started 40 years
ago with 52 American dip
that's who were taken hostage and held
for 444 days this thing didn't start
with me it didn't end with me it
continues on this industry of taking
hostages in Iran but my hope is that
that they'll be reunited and I hope that
the Trump administration does a lot more
than they have been doing to bring these
people home yeah your family really put
a lot of pressure I interviewed your
brother on there really champing for
your release you know it requires a
major effort by family your employers
and the US government great to have you
thank you so much great to meet your
wife
you had your beer night thank you
prisoner goes on sale tomorrow